a tiny chef and his little helpers are
preparing a pina colada
as a teaser and anticipation of the real
deal images that look incredibly real
projected onto the sculpted surface of
the bar all made possible thanks to 3d
video technology the film was the
brainchild of Belgian video artists
Anton Trebek and Philip sterics of skull
mapping the idea was to make a like a
bar but not just a normal bar but also
put a part in like a sculpture because
the bar is usually flat so just to make
it come alive more or look more 3d today
viewers are seeing the unfinished
animated video called cocktail bar for
the first time and now it's this is the
end piece of what we have so far for
misses at first I've never seen anything
like this it's a great idea I told you
it's like video it's a sculpture it's a
scenery it's like an entire package they
deliver it's not just visuals but it's
actually started happening in front of
your eyes like a watching a real-life
movie skull mapping posted their first
video flippity chef's online in 2015 so
far it has received over 39 million
clicks whoa you
[Music]
Oh
it's nice to create a small world an
imaginary world and and to use some
fantasy in this and in the case of the
padishah for the the cocktail bar it's
like a small guy in a big world so
that's that's a lot of fun skull mapping
sell their videos to restaurants and
event organizers the world over in this
video the chef follows in the footsteps
of Marco Polo this is part of a meal
with several courses it is on show in a
restaurant in Dubai and we'll come to
Berlin soon the gallery invasion video
followed in 2016 it features a monkey
pursuing a graffiti artist
the video artist used a rotating mirror
for this animation it enabled them to
project the video throughout the entire
room what we make it's very approachable
and it's for problem ages for all ages
you know everybody can enjoy it and
that's I think that's also very
rewarding for us it's so many people
different kind of people from different
kind of layers of society enjoy your
work so the virtual worlds aren't just
created on the computer acting talent is
also called for for many of their videos
skull mapping use motion capture a
technique that captures human movements
and portrays them three dimensionally on
the computer
the artists then place the figures in
their virtual scenes and process them
[Music]
the special thing about their latest
animation is that it's projected onto a
handmade 3d landscape
I mean we're really we love to
experiment with every new project we're
doing and learn something new and I find
a new technique and at the end of the
day tell a story in a in a new way
cocktail bar is due for completion with
sound effects this summer Philip Starck
San Anton for BIC plan to post it online
and hope that soon it will be available
in selected bars the world over
you